wenige wochen vor dem bevorstehenden
auslandseinsatz im kosovo erhält das
jägerbataillon 18 aus sankt michael in
der steiermark neue schutzausrüstung und
das von verteidigungsministerin klaudia
tanner höchstpersönlich ich freue mich
wirklich besonders dass ich heute dem
jägerbataillon 18 symbolisch einen teil
der schutzausrüstung übergeben kann
insgesamt bekommt das bataillon 120
setzte diese schutzausrüstung zur
ausbildung und für den einsatz
zugewiesen die ausrüstung umfasst neben
einem flammhemmenden overall einen
einsatz helm schutzhandschuhe
atemschutzmaske ballistischen
schutzwesten arm und bein protektoren
und natürlich das schutzschild
kompaniekommandant mario fruhmann zeigt
sich über die neue ausrüstung jedenfalls
überaus erfreut die alte ausrüstung oder
15 jahre alt und jetzt verfügen wir
wirklich für eine zeitgemäße ausrüstung
da ich so meinen auslandseinsätzen noch
gar nicht beobachten konnte wir verfügen
über alles für eine person
das andere einsatz am ende einzeln kamen
das macht noch mehr stolz als
österreichischer soldat die republik
österreich ins ausland zu gehen
die ausrüstung wird vor allem in
sogenannten crc szenarien benötigt cr z
steht für fraud and ride control oder
überwachung von unfriedlichen
menschenansammlungen und eindämmung von
krawallen kein unwahrscheinliches
szenario in krisengebieten deshalb auch
regelmäßig und realitätsnah geübt wird
[Musik]
auch eine einweisung in die neue
ausrüstung durch den
kompaniekommandanten betont
verteidigungsministerin tanner noch den
hohen stellenwert angemessener
schutzausrüstung
es gibt nichts wichtigeres als die
gesundheit den schutz unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten an dieser
stelle noch einmal alles alles gute für
den bevorstehenden einsatz und die
letzten trainingstage
insgesamt wird das jägerbataillon 18 mit
circa 100 soldaten ab ende september für
sechs monate friedenssichernde aufgaben
in kosovo erfüllen